احنا بالنسبه للنسيق الامن في عندنا نظريه
انه محاربه الارهاب اينما كان
اين مكان
وهون في نقطه مهمه يمكن ما حد بعرفها احنا
عاقدين اتفاقيات
لمحاربه الارهاب والعنف مع 85 دوله في
العالم على راسه مين الولايات المتحده
وكندا وبريطانيا وروسيا واليابان واليوم
اخر شيء اليوم اليوم وقعنا مع القبر
احنا من حيث المبدا ضد الارهاب ضد العنف
وايضا مع اسرائيل نحن ضد الارهاب لكن اذا
استمرت اسرائيل بتصرفاتها انا ليش اكمل
ليش اكون ملتزم
بالتفاقي
التزامي بالاتفاق الامريكي اذا استمرت
اسرائيل
تضرب بعرض الحائط كل
القضايا كل الامور الانسانيه والسياسيه
اللي بيننا وبينه
تهديد بوقف التنسيق الامني البعض يطالب
فيه ويقول انه ضد المصلحه الفلسطينيه
البعد الاخر يقول انه لا هذا الفلسطيني لا
يستطيع ان يتنفس الا من خلال هذا التنصير
نعرف
نتنفسنا
وشعبنا موجود
الاحتلال
كاني قارئ بالقوه السلاح هلا احنا منقرع
بالقوه
المقاومه الشعبيه السلميه التي لا تقل عن
السلاح الان المقاومه الشعبيه في كل مكان
في كل مكان
لها اثارها ولها
نتائج التي التي يلمسها الاسرائيليون وفي
ايضا مقاومه مسلحه بدا تظهر بالفتره
الاخيره وكان في توسع لها يقال بانه
العمليات اكثر من نسبه العمليات اللي كانت
ب 2015
بس انا بالنسبه للمقاومه العسكريه
مش متبنيها هلا انا ممكن تغير رايك
ما يكونش متغير ما احنا كنا احنا كيف
نشانا
انا واحد
اهلا وسهلا بالمقاومه
النادي الدولي طيب في التسعين
اوكي
بيعمل اي شيء وانا
بانبه وبحضر انه
اياكم
توصلوا الشعب الفلسطيني بان يفقد صبره